samantha qui est un bon soir samantha ci
d'être là samantha vous avez 19 ans
merci témoigner ce soir vous venez du
var vous avez vécu un drame puisque
votre papa s'est suicidé et si on parle
de ça ce soir c'est que ça a énormément
joué dans ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
est ce que vous voulez pour demain votre
papa s'est suicidé parce qu'il avait
trop de dettes il pouvait plus assumer
il avait trop d'angoissé et par rapport
à bout voilà apparemment il y voit là
s'il pouvait plus assumer et il a mis
fin à sa vie
alors mon pape avait 46 ans donc c'est
en septembre dernier
ça faisait palois n'est peut-être un peu
plus d'un an qu'il avait ouvert son
restaurant
mon père a travaillé toute sa vie les
grands postes il a eu d'autres
restaurants et donc il a décidé d'ouvrir
un restaurant familial donc avec moi et
ma mère est donc le resteront en
eux-mêmes marche bien mais le problème
c'est qu'il n'a pas été aidé au départ
qu'il a dû faire des crédits sur des
crédits sur des crédits et pour être
honnête il en a fait faire même ma
grand-mère à ma mère donc voilà il a
essayé
il a essayé de tout faire pour rattraper
mais même malgré tout ça le manque d'
aide les taxes qui sont énormes parce
que du coup quand mon père est mort ben
ma mère m'en a lu regardé ou faire voir
un peu les comptes tout ça et
honnêtement je me suis marié le 24 août
le 5 septembre
en fait je ne fais passer mon bac le
lendemain et j'ai reçu un appel de ma
mère comme quoi mon père si celui-ci est
tout seul dans la mer un drame parce
qu'il n'en ferait plus ça faisait
longtemps qu'il n'avait plus la nuit
qu'il avait plu est vrai que c'est plus
quoi faire pour eux sauvé il avait la
maison bon moi je suis partie avec mes
enfants et mon mari ne savait plus quoi
faire pour se sortir de là il avait tout
essayé et il en a demandé des aides il a
été voir des personnes
il ya vraiment tout est fini alors ça
monte à votre témoignage y ont voient
tout le monde est vraiment à votre
écoute parce que on se dit il ya eu ce
drame avant est ce que vous pensiez
avant ce drame
voter pour marine le pen j'avais déjà
commencé
le pont quoi est-ce que vous avez très
jeune j'avais 19 ans oui oui le problème
c'est que je vois que moi depuis
toujours j'ai toujours été très
débrouillard j'ai toujours passé mes
diplômes j'ai toujours eu des gens qui
se marient à 19 ans déjà six extraits
enfin si mais là c'est fou mais je me
suis toujours battu j'ai essayé de faire
le maximum de ce que je pouvais et j'ai
essayé de faire le plus de manuel
j'étais dans le plein entreprise et j'ai
vraiment fait énormément de choses et
quand je vois que moi quand je à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai fait un service civique donc je
peux à 6,5 connaissent c'est un peu
comme du bénévolat payer à minima je
vois que je devais être embauché dans
les travées dans une école primaire chez
moi je devais être embauchés bon ça ne
s'est pas fait donc j'ai trouvé un
travail de dernière minute je suis
auxiliaire de vie à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
et pourtant j'ai des diplômes donc comme
quoi les diplômés mais qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait voter pour marine le pen
justement c'est que je vois que moi je
me lève le matin tous les jours pour
gagner 1000 2003 et quand je vois qu'il
y en a en restant à la maison en faisant
rien il gagne la même chose que moi et
on peut pas me dire que c'est faux parce
que je le sais j'en connais des gens
comme ça qui restent à la maison qui
travaillent pas ils ont lu jamais rien
fait et touche pareil que moi et aussi
en quoi marine le pen va changer ça mais
elle limite que les cheveux qui les aide
pour ceux qui pour tout le monde c'est
normal il faut qu'il soit dégagé on va
mal et on peut pas mener en france on a
cette chance d'aider et d'avoir dévoilé
le gouvernement est allé je ne dis pas
que les aides c'est pas bien parce que
moi j'en ai eu besoin j'ai pas honte de
le dire parce que j'étais maman très
jeune on n'a pas envie de voir des gens
dans la rue voilà exactement je veux
qu'il soit égal pour tout le monde mais
quand c'est alors devrait pas du tout
égal mais je quand je vois que les
jeunes je comprends je le siège va pas
se mentir il ya déjà une île on prend du
travail est prêt il y en a qui préfèrent
faire la fête et travailler plus tard
tout ça mais quand il ya des jeunes qui
ont envie de travailler qui se défendent
tous les jours qui font des projections
de ça et qu'au final y'a rien et
pourtant on a et c'est pas faute
d'essayer je vais pas vous dire j'en ai
fait des choses et tous ceux qui avec
qui j'ai travaillé ils le savent tous
les projets qu'ils essaient de mener
mais il n'y a jamais rien qui marche
parce qu'on a
dette on n'est pas aidés on est laissé
un peu à l'abandon et donc aujourd'hui
vous avez décidé de voter marine le pen
en 2022 oui si ammann je peux te la
beauté mais qu'est ce qui vous séduit
mais j'imagine donc improbable premier
vote que vous allez faire de votre vie
ce sera pour moi pour marine le pen
après peut-être qu'il y en a qui diront
bien tu vas le regretter ou quoi mais
jusqu'à maintenant tout on l'a dit tout
à l'heure tous les partis ont été
essayées et est ce que ça va changer
quelque chose moi c'est vraiment c'est
ça qui me fait peur il vous dit parce
que moi j'ai et moi je c'est vrai que je
suis d'une génération et je dis moi le
front national rassemble deux romans
rassemblement national de fait peur
comme karim je suis sûr qu'il est comme
moi également comme beaucoup de sa table
et c'est vrai que ça me fait peur mais
on entend ça c'est ça qui est grave
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas vraiment
d'adhésion pour la plupart je suis
désolé de vous dire ça j'en messia c'est
que c'est souvent on a essayé à droite à
gauche pourquoi pas ça sera pas pire que
les autres
c'est ça la principale phrase qu'on
entend aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on entend
chez cette jeune dame avant cette jeune
fille samantha non c'est pas avancer en
ménage bien entendu tout à domicile ça
je ferai un programme qui tient la route
qu'elle fera une catastrophe si son
pouvoir
la catastrophe aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est pas une catastrophe comme un homme
de 46 ans père de famille madoff s'est
fait sur des expériences qui les a
embêtés parce qu'ils n'arrivent pourtant
sont inversés et une politique nationale
sur une obsession pour un nombre
d'étrangers qui est extrêmement minime
et ce concours à le redire ban est
restée quasiment pas ou est ce que j'ai
pas l'immigration à l'étranger l'un
d'eux était en débat des mois je parle
de programme de fond mais parce que
votre obsession ne correspond et eric
naulleau l'éditeur en rien aux priorités
du front national c'est la priorité du
front national c'est l'obsession de les
traîner le soir et donc les problèmes
nationaux la france passe c'est ne
servir que d'anciens l'américain jack
discours de marine le pen du début de
son discours à la fin de son discours
elle ne parle toute immigration non
c'est non
vous savez ça résister dans le discours
mais parce que ça reste du japon des
ronds dans l'eau
c'est un peu comme on dit c'est vrai que
l'immigration est la cause de tous les
problèmes quand on regarde le programme
de marine le pen non mais attendez je
suis bien placé pour parler du propre de
marine le pen j'étais son col le
coordinateur du projet présidentiel en
2017 donc je peux vous parler du
programme
je vous ai pas de nom mais voilà mais
non mais vous on part du programme est
ce que je peux en caser une comme sur le
programme ah oui le projet samantha
voudrais vous remercier va témoigner et
samantha
j'ai une pensée pour votre papa il
paraît qu'on puisse y regarder beaucoup
nos émissions à du matin au soir
on a mangé du sirha le marriage le
métier les rivalités de réglisse on a
mangé du lion en tout cas merci sam on
cherche